cette à jérusalem sur le mention que se
trouve cette grotte du souvenir
éclairé par six bougies une bougie par
millions de morts dans ces urnes des
cendres qui proviennent de dar al darbi
de ravensbrück où d'ailleurs de tous les
camps de la mort un simple hôtel sur cet
autel et autour de lui des reliques
tél ce drapeau de la révolte du ghetto
de varsovie
tel ce talent aide à moitié brûlé qui
vient de quelque part en allemagne
tels ces tables de la loi profané tél
ces morceaux de savon qui étaient
fabriqués dans les camps de la mort
des échantillons des cristaux qui
provoquait les gaz mortels
une corde qui a servi à pendre
pour cette crypte des israéliens ont
trouvé un nom la chambre de la
destruction
le principal responsable de toutes ces
destructions
c'est adolf eichmann qui se trouve
maintenant quelque part en israël sous
les verrous et cesse avec la même
émotion sur tout le territoire israélien
qui a été connue l'arrestation d'adolph
eichmann les juifs avaient enfin arrêter
leurs assassins celui qu'il recherchait
depuis de très longues années
c'est monsieur ben gourion premier
ministre d'israël qu'annonce à lui même
la nouvelle au parlement de jérusalem
cette déclaration qui fige une voix
tremblante d'émotion il a accepté de la
répéter pour nous on est premiers
chevreuil a allié de m
les forces de sécurité israéliennes ont
découvert très récemment l'un des plus
grand criminel de guerre nazi adolf
eichmann
l'homme qui a inventé réaliser la
solution définitive à la question gym
c'est à dire l'extermination de six
millions de juifs européens
adolf eichmann sera bientôt jugé en
israël selon la juridiction prévues à
l'encontre des nazis et de leurs
collaborateurs président expliquer
pourquoi le gouvernement israélien est
toujours aussi secret sur les conditions
de l'arrestation des chevals
gouvernement ne sait que ce que les
services de sécurité ont bien voulu dire
iceman est entre les mains de la police
le gouvernement n'a pas cherché à savoir
comment ils avaient été attirés
il avait été capturé
gouvernement donc ne sait pas tout ce
que les services de sécurité ça de quoi
vraiment à chaque station
est ce que vous considérez monsieur le
président adolf eichmann est vraiment le
criminel de guerre numéro un pour le
peuple d'israël
certainement l'un des plus grands qu'il
est le numéro 1 c'était type l'air mais
hitler je suppose mais plus de ce monde
il n'est pas possible de savoir où et
schumann est en prison actuellement
présager une possible
no way il est en prison entre les mains
de la police
et ce sont des mains sûres en quittant
la maison de monsieur ben gourion nous
n'avions plus qu'à les rendre visite à
tel aviv à monsieur marc niasse chef de
la police israélienne pour essayer d'en
savoir davantage vous pouvez vous
et bien malheureusement rien du tout
mme a été livré en israël il ya une
semaine quelles ont été les réactions
lorsqu'il a su se trouvait en israël qui
ne débat était il ne m'a pas paru très
étonné à part cela je ne peux pas
indiquer des
manifestation de réactions soient en
paroles ou en fait comment est une
préférée quand il est traité en détenus
dans le cas et
ces enquêtes peut-on dire qu'il est en
prison
peut-on dire qu'il est ailleurs et il
est en prison
est ce que les mesures spéciales ont été
prises pour le garder oui en vue de
d'assurer sa sécurité et sa présence est
il exact voulu être gardée par des
policiers qui ne sont pas européens
c'est-à-dire dont les familles n'ont pas
eu à souffrir directement des atrocités
nation oui autant que possible est-ce
qu'il a des contacts avec le monde
extérieur
non pas du tout qu'en pensez vous que le
procès aura lieu
eh bien il m'est très difficile de faire
des
de vous donner des indications en ce
moment puisque
nous nous voir nous venons de commencer
les enquêtes mais
[Musique]
l'intention de mon gouvernement sait que
les procès le procès ait eu lieu
aussitôt que possible
vous pensez qu'on servait secret la
résidence teichmann pendant longtemps et
autant que possible oui est ce que vous
pensez qu'un jour on connaîtra toute la
vérité sur l'arrestation de chemin je ne
sais pas si on connaîtra mais je pense
que
on ne va pas donner les détails
officiellement avez vous été aidé par
des organismes ou avait personne
étrangère je n'ai pas connaissance
personnelle de cela mais je pense que
qu'il a été dit officiellement que non
combien estimez-vous et qu'il ya de
personne en israël qui soit complètement
dans le secret de l'arrestation des
chemins enfin 10 15 pas beaucoup plus et
malheureusement pour nous ne faisons pas
partie de ces quelques privilégiés où se
trouve
adolf eichmann c'est la question que se
posent les journalistes du monde entier
si on ne sait pas où il est on a tout au
moins la consolation de savoir où il a
été on sait qu'à son arrivée en israël
il fut détenu dans cette ancienne prison
arabe de jaffa et par les barreaux de sa
cellule il a pu apercevoir ce pays qu'il
a essayé d'étouffer à sa naissance
mais aujourd'hui où est-il peut-être
dans l'une des stations de police
construite par les enlever à l'époque du
mandat et qui tisse une véritable toile
d'araignée sur tout le territoire
il est probablement dans une cellule qui
ressemble à celle ci que savent
exactement les israéliens sur adolf
eichmann ils ont des photos
ils ont surtout des témoignages directs
de ceux qui l'ont connu pendant la
guerre tél jodel brent qui était le chef
de la communauté juive de hongrie est
acquis eichmann a fait des propositions
monstrueuse
[Musique]
un million de juifs qu'entre dix mille
camions
il m'a dit je suis prêt à vous vendre un
million de juifs marchandises contre
chair humaine chaire humaine contre
marchandises il a proposé de faire ça
comme un contrat il commencé par livrer
cent mille juifs et puis après nous
donnions 1000 camions et puis la faire a
été retardée de quatre mois et demi
combien de fois avez vous vu eichmann
cinq fois avez vous l'impression que
vous trouvez en face d'un monstre pas
l'impression la certitude
je savais qu'il était l'organisateur de
la mort de millions d'êtres humains
c'était lui l'organisateur des chambres
à gaz
[Musique]
après la fin de la guerre avez vous
cherché à le retrouver
je n'ai jamais rien eu d'autre en tête
que de chercher et de retrouver iceman
et ses comptes us vous saviez qu'il
était vivant
j'en étais sûr par tout ce que j'ai
appris de sa femme de ses enfants de sa
famille de ses soeurs aussi et de
plusieurs nazis où l'avez-vous
spécialement chercher à peu près dans
tous les pays du monde
partout ils pouvaient se trouver est il
vraiment pour vous le criminel de guerre
numéro un
ça ne fait pas de questions iceman est
le plus grand criminel de guerre pour
israël quel sera votre impression quand
vous vous retrouverez face à face avec
lui dans une prison en israël
des impressions je n'en sais rien
l'avenir le dira mais j'aurai beaucoup
beaucoup de questions à lui poser en
plus de ces témoignages accablants il y
aura les documents ces documents se
trouvent actuellement dans un bâtiment
des environs de jérusalem au yad vashem
qui est dirigée par le docteur qubo vie
ce sont les archives de l'histoire du
peuple juif
quel genre de document docteur pourront
trouver les enquêteurs au bâtiment dans
nos archives nous avons réuni ici tout
le document qui ont rapport à
l'extermination de la population juive
d'europe
nous avons ici et le document du
ministère affaires étrangères nazis nous
avons le dossier personnel de adolf
eichmann nous avons des témoignages qui
ont été réunis au cours de nombreuses
années
le grand problème est la définition du
cac à hermann parce que adolphe à
hermann est lié à tous les aspects à
toutes les phases de l'extermination de
la population juive en sommes à tous les
camps d'extermination et il sera très
difficile de délimiter le procès je
disais l'autre jour dans un journal
allemand que adolf eichmann n'avait pas
l'habitude de signer lui-même les ordres
qu'il donnait nous avons ici un très
grand nombre de documents signés de sa
main et qui constituent des ordres qui
constituent des ordres de déportation et
qui ont rapport au traitement spécial
parce que jamais les allemands n'ont
parlé d'extermination il employait
l'euphémisme zone durban loc
mais chacun sait ce que cela signifie
d'autre part nous avons des témoignages
écrits et par ses lieutenants nous avons
ici écrit de sa propre main le
témoignage d'un de ses lieutenants
principaux détaillants de wisches
lituanie où il expose de façon précise
le rôle joué par adam tarbah et
maintenant kezman est arrêté et que vous
savez que le procès va s'ouvrir c'est
une question de semaines mois du temps
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
faire de nouvelles recherches pour
trouver de nouveaux documents ce n'est
pas notre rôle à proprement parler nous
continuons à réunir les documents parce
que nous préparons ici en général le
procès de l'histoire d'ailleurs comme
adolf eichmann et n'est que le symbole
d'une époque le symbole d'un régime ce
n'est pas la personne d'herman en
elle-même qui nous intéresse ou qui
intéresse le monde
ce qui est intéressant c'est le régime
et l'extermination karibe le procès du
génocide qui le représente votre voulait
beaucoup plus celui d'un historien et
celui d'un enquêteur de paul évidemment
ça c'est notre rôle c'est mais c'est un
allemand c'est schiller qui a dit que
l'histoire du monde et le jugement du
monde
il existe donc de nombreux documents
accablants signé par eichmann lui-même
mais au dossier on trouvera également
des témoignages personnels
en effet la police a décidé d'ouvrir une
boîte postale spécial pour permettre à
tous ceux qui d'une façon ou d'une autre
ont souffert les atrocités d'adolph
eichmann d'envoyer leurs témoignages et
toutes ces lettres que chaque jour un
policier vient chercher au bureau de
poste sont autant de documents qui
viendront grossir le dossier
adolf eichmann et bien voilà tout ce que
nous avons pu apprendre sur le cas
eichmann
il ya encore de nombreuses inconnues
qu'en sera-t-il jugé comment sera-t-il
jugé par qui sera t il jugé
autant de questions auxquelles nous
pouvons pas répondre pour l'instant nous
savons même pas si le tribunal quel
qu'il soit
appliquera la liberté qui lui est laissé
de prononcer la peine de mort car en
effet la peine de mort a été supprimée
en israël sauf pour un seul cas le crime
de génocide
adolf eichmann sera t-il trouvé coupable
de ce crime ne seront certainement pas
avant plusieurs bains
[Musique]